je suis tombé sur une histoire d'amour
très mignonne aux etats unis un homme et
une femme se retrouvent et se marient
soixante trois ans après leur premier et
cela est vrai c'est annette et bob
ils se sont embrassés pour la première
fois un soir de juin 1956 lors d'un bal
étudiants en virginie et j'ai ensuite
fait chacun leur vie se sont mariés mais
il ya quelques années sont devenues
veuves tous les deux et ils se sont
retrouvés
on est content ou pas pas beau l'amour
voilà l'amour alors est-ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter vous votre premier
amour votre premier baiser c'est et qui
vous paraît valérie benaïm technique
le premier premier baiser j'étais en
troisième j'étais amoureuse du cancre de
la classe
non le vrai oui le voyou quoi ouais
c'est lui qui répond aux profs qui part
en colle tout le temps qui au fond de la
classe qui séchait les cours pour ça
tout ça y ressemble à david bowie mais
en plus l'assemblage david baudon et
voilà donc j'étais amoureuse de lui et
on a eu un petit bisou à un nom mais les
files faut nous expliquer quoi ce que
vous êtes attiré par les bad boys a pas
moins de bye
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
au moment où je pense que c'est une
question existentielle eux nous on est
justement en étant moi j'étais une élève
exonhit ouvrage très car oui c'est bien
mais généralement les mof comme ça sont
attirés par les vagues et les meufs je
me rappelle georges avait jamais j'ai
vol je sortais souvent était première de
la classe ça c'est vrai et après ça
s'est dégradé
tu rappelles de ton premier baiser toi
car on voit la première fois elle avait
sérieusement justement ça devait elle la
bad boy de la bad girl
parce qu'elle avait dit un truc de
partout si tu l'as qui fait pas je
l'utilisé comme le montrait point que
c'est vrai at war et c'était la première
meuf
ouais tu embrasses tester ou canada
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant que j'étais plus dans la
relation sexuelle le premier baiser
c'est autre chose c'est une fille dont
j'étais amoureux depuis très tellement
longtemps piquant gelé finalement
pechos1 j'embrasse est tellement mal
alors toutes ses copines qui sont venu
m'expliquer comment away m'a dit que ça
allait ouvrir un peu la bouche ouverte
mon premier baiser c'était à 6 ans il
vient de lever 6,6 aussi ça alors ça
c'est en outre wakata manger sucré
alors donc c'était s'éteignent et télé
c'était à grenoble et l'italie défend
fort avec les nains qui m'a fait tomber
matériel est ébranlée déjà contrairement
à lui c'était la saison dernière le
premier et le dernier
non non non non je la connais je peux
vous allez à là il n'aurait mon succès
énormément de succès vous l'atout
premier baiser c'était quoi vous attend
pour alors moi on arrêtait que moi mais
attendez il ya l'invité ya tout d'abord
même intéressé à fada a bien je m'en
rappellerai le baiser je me rappelle
c'est toi c'est ans m
oui exactement étaient comme à ses mains
je n'ai pas grandi de
[Rires]
ouais c'est main elle s'appelle
alexandra non et on était très jeune et
on s'étend pas sont scellés bien se
tenait par la main et on sait là on se
doute bien que tu avais pas quarante
deux ans et en ont sauté à la corde
toute la journée
ah ouais ouais encore on l'adoré ça te
vois tu vas en matière de son toit pour
des anecdotes de bien coller signal je
sais que c'est vous qui m'avez demandé
cette hausse était contre 18 en toi
ouais ça premier baiser échangé au
cinéma on était premiers amours un beau
jour qui vient à te rencontrer voix cd
j'avais 18 ans eric deux premiers duels
ça c'était c'était c'était mignon en
fait ça c'était au départ un bisou qui
se transforme en baiser donc il ya eu un
petit déclic a dit quoi la différence à
dire ma cabane ces partis mais chut
mobile ou voilà comme ça et moi j'ai ma
place
allo
regardez j'ai insisté la star record
mondial c'est un baiser entre onze
générations d'écart l'aja mais c'est
fait ça n'a jamais été fait en
télévision en direct chabrette
simplement regarder juste renchérit sur
la place que vous acceptez d'être
embrassé match ou pas du tout être qui
veulent embrasser ou sur la bouche voilà
des bisous ça se transforme en
exactement ce qui s'est passé alors je
chuchote des petits mots gentils
tu es très jolie elle avait fait
exactement ce que tu appelles parlant
quand même des fois c'est tout le débat
s'était pas le french kiss
c'était une espèce de trampoline avec
les lèvres le témoin parce qu'il avait
18 ans n'empêche
en fait une série de petits snacks à les
tuer très chaud ni froid ni trop molle
est il trop pauline trop poli pour
pauline comprenait la radio et voilà est
bon pour mon côté qu à freiner fricoter
n'ont pas les couilles si cette histoire
est vraie le bien de couper miotte mais
c'est vrai franchement cette histoire je
n'y crois pas pas à vous rappeler
frédéric et j'avais il s'appelait
frédéric l'avait mal vu epinal dans les
vosges j'en suis la finale je sais et je
faisais du la voltige à cheval
elle aboutit à cheval comme les cosaques
saumon du cheval au concours externe
mais tombe amoureux d'une fille faisait
du galop enfin du saut d'obstacles bien
sûr je donne rendez vous dans un ou des
spas des étables des boxes de deux
chevaux s'appelait fripons cheval et
jeudi mais moi je mange et on faisait le
palefrenier arrive a déjà décroché un ca
et du coup je m'occupe de chasse je les
rejoins moi dans là dans le box de free
peau que ça je l'attends l arrivée au
fameux serment que je ferais fripons je
vois qu'il était plus en plus en forme
et elle arrive du saumon il était mais
on forme
mon dieu
et du coup j'ai mordu branché nice et
pour un premier baiser y avait l'autre
qui bandent est que ce corps it et donc
du temps de s'embrasser devant un truc
qu'on peut corriger rives vous lire dans
sa mairie par jean marie besset ben
barnes répond c'est aussi la pouliche à
lévis